block has released a financial report on
bitcoin it's 19 pages in total but there
are a few slides that we want to check
out today specifically talking about why
people do not buy bitcoin today let's
see if we can pull up the report and
look at uh two pages in particular so
here's one page from the report that i
thought was particularly interesting
from block they said the lack of bitcoin
knowledge is the top reason people do
not buy it right so 51 of the people
that were uh chosen for this survey said
they don't know enough about it right
there's other reasons like cyber
security or too much price volatility
uncertainty uncertain around regulatory
outlook etc but 51 of the people that
said they have not bought bitcoin said
that they don't know much about it and
if we go to the next chart uh there's
another one here that talks about the
level of knowledge that impacts bitcoin
purchasing so the knowledge levels and
intent to buy the percent who are likely
to purchase bitcoin in the next 12
months
fair to expert levels of cryptocurrency
knowledge 41 but when you move to the
group that has limited to no knowledge
of cryptocurrency it's eight percent are
likely right so the odds of someone
purchasing bitcoin specifically or
crypto in general within the next 12
months based on their knowledge base
changes dramatically right you go from
41 to just 8
and i think this speaks to the broader
point of what we were talking about
earlier which is education around
bitcoin but finance in general is the
number one thing that we could be doing
bar none right because not only do
people not understand what's happening
to them from an inflation standpoint
they're not budgeting correctly in a lot
of cases they're not uh they don't
understand what investable assets do how
how compound interest works like there's
a million things you can talk about but
bitcoin is a perfect example of the
amount of people that gain knowledge
about it go down that rapid hole learn
about it and purchase it is probably
higher than most other industries at
this point because of the value add that
they have and the selling points of uh
of money that can be not being not being
manipulated right decentralized money
money that your government cannot
interfere with money that is
peer-to-peer and does not take uh an
intermediary in between right so there's
like once you figure out exactly how it
works it's almost like a light bulb goes
off and you're like oh [ __ ] like this
makes sense like i should probably start
checking this out a little more and you
learn and you learn and you learn and
maybe you end up buying or maybe you
don't but the point is if you have no
knowledge we just saw from the report
your likelihood of buying is eight
percent in the next 12 months right so
uh i think ed financial education in
general and when it comes to crypto and
bitcoin specifically is the most
important thing we could be doing it can
quite literally change lives
quite literally because not only are you
uh getting people more educated but
you're putting them in a better
financial position which helps them
which helps their family which could
help generations of people if you do it
in the correct way so i think that if
the schools aren't going to teach you
this if the universities aren't going to
teach you this if you're not going to
learn this from an educational structure
that we have in the united states today
it's up to you and it's never been
easier to learn right this is a youtube
show this is open to anyone this is open
borders you can literally log in from
anywhere in the world that has a
connection to youtube and you can watch
this video you can do this with millions
of other people that are creating
content in a similar fashion and whether
it's bitcoin or something else i think
financial education is really the
sticking point of what people need to be
focused on what do you think john i
agree it brings me back to the quote of
henry ford that i thought about why you
were talking which is it is well enough
that if people of the nation do not
understand banking and monetary system
for if they did i believe there would be
a revolution before tomorrow morning and
it talks about just the education of
people not understanding what is really
happening and that's why i'm honestly
glad that i found one bitcoin for the
technology and the asset and the price
appreciation and everything else but
also it led me down the rabbit hole of a
bunch of other things so led me down the
rabbit hole of inflation and getting off
the um the gold standard and all these
things that kind of go along with what
bitcoin can do it just leads you down
this uh this rabbit hole of this path to
just learn more and more about
our monetary system the global monetary
system how everything's work how our
communications channels how is money
actually transmitted who are the middle
men that are just transmitting taking
fees of your money right um they are
providing a service but they take fees a
lot of the time that is unnecessary
right so it just goes it goes back to
harping on education i always think
about like what can you do from the
education standpoint it's one of the
reasons why we obviously started this
show but it's really what can you do
from an education standpoint to help the
next person to help the next generation
um and setting up those things and those
structures i think is the best thing
that you could possibly do yeah i think
in a lot of cases too uh
the lack of interest in it is is a
problem right but i think that that lack
of interest comes from not knowing the
consequences right so people are always
like uh i talk to people my friends
don't want to talk about this no one
else wants to talk about this bitcoin
specifically they think i'm annoying but
the idea i think needs to be reframed
where you talk about the consequences of
not understanding this and not even
bitcoin specifically but just financial
education right so from everything that
i just mentioned i guarantee if you show
someone or you explain to someone
exactly what is happening from a money
printing perspective how much money was
ejected injected into the economy what
that did to asset prices who benefited
the most and who got hurt the most
that's like the only selling point you
need right for someone that doesn't
invest for someone that doesn't care
about investing for someone that doesn't
care about financial education those are
very obvious selling points right your
wealth is being devalued away everything
you're buying is getting more expensive
around you and you're not getting a
raise right you're literally better off
than you were while everyone else around
you is making money and was pumped up
last year their 401ks were going to
all-time highs their brokerage accounts
were going all-time highs their crypto
accounts were going to all-time highs
you were sitting there and you were in a
worse off financial position because
maybe you got a two percent raise a five
percent raise but at the end of the day
everything you're buying is more
expensive you're in a shittier situation
asset prices have gone up you didn't
benefit from that so i think it's more
about reframing it from hey let me teach
you about bitcoin and it's hey let me
show you the consequences of not being
financially educated and taking control
of your own financial life i think
that's a better way to frame it rather
than just trying to teach people about
bitcoin